[Musique]
peut se penser la télévision et un est
un moyen d'expression qui peut se passer
du découpage et du gros plan quoi qu'on
en dise et du plan d'ensemble je vois
que la télévision est une chose qu'on
doit voir comme un journal et qu'on doit
mettre en page comme un journal c'est à
dire qu'il n'ya pas de la recherche et
la division de profondeur dans le champ
qu'un écran est trop petit pour qu'on
puisse vraiment l'apprécier pour monfils
a subi
je crois qu'une image de telles
illusions qui va se dire du premier coup
et non plus être dû au montage rapide ça
n'existe pas je vois que le spectateur
doit analyser parce qu'il le peut parce
qu'il est tout près du poste parce qu'il
est attentif parce que ils dominent de
postes alors que l'écran le domine
degrandi grande fille m'a jugé le domine
le spectateur lui domine son poste et
donc il peut analyser l'image très
finement à condition qu'ils regardent la
télévision
non pas en mangeant mais on regarde la
division convoi de regarder ça diront ça
vaut rien d'autre de toute manière
c'était un bureau avec paul lanchere
grincer des dents ou bien la course du
texte à cause de la subversion même du
texte même et en place à cause du
découpage car jamais je ne me suis je me
suis efforcé du moins de les détruire la
notion de raccords dans le temps dans
l'espace il voulait les gens
apparaissent quand j'aurai besoin quand
ils en ont le plus besoin et
disparaissent et puis sans doute c'est
un hommage que j'ai rendu la jarrie
karila il pas écrit du roi pour comme ça
il a préféré une préface cette pièce qui
s'appelle dans une lettre fameuse de
l'inutilité du théâtre au théâtre
et ouais je crois que j'ai fait deux
lignes du diacre à la télévision pour
faire de la télévision je vois il faut
oublier toutes les formes d'expression
avec qui l'ont précédé car je crois pour
vous des mandalas vertus spécifiques de
des visions que ben langage d'expression
non pas comme véhicule programme
oui écoutez là je vais demander beaucoup
d'indulgence aux spectateurs aux
montants qu'il veut qu'ils astienne de
faire des critiques je réclame et même
si les critiques sont vives en terre
serbe est bien juste ça sera de
l'enseignement profond droit car je
pense que les gens qui croient que au
moins leur métier ou du moins qui rend
fou l'horizon profonde de vivre ont
besoin de se faire engueuler pour réagir
mais je lui demande au spectateur que je
ne connais pas mais que je sais être à
monsieur intelligent je lui demande ce
soir là non pas de regarder la
télévision comme rouvre son frigidaire
pour gracier du jambon du boulet pour
manger que je trouve quelque chose de
bon mais de faire un effort
supplémentaire au risque de le trouver
vide ce poste même s'il est déçu sur le
résultat final du spectacle lui demande
de faire l'effort d'aidé mais au moins
l'effort que j'ai fait moi l'actualité
des tournages nous conduit aujourd'hui à
joinville ou jean christophe averty
essaye de trouver une écriture peut être
plus simple moins agressive qui leur
considéré avec la majorité des
téléspectateurs et bien une conception
bien changé depuis cinq ans je continue
à déplaire et je le déplore
malheureusement tant que je pourrai
faire les variétés comme je les aime
quand j'ai qu'on soit je continuerai
parce que je pense que de temps en temps
il faut qu'un metteur en scène quitte à
déplaire à tout le monde continue à
chercher quelque chose quitte à ne rien
trouver ce qui est mon cas apparaissent
apparemment d'après les critiques la
plupart des spectateurs qui ont été ils
ont chez eux ne la respecte pas et la
considère comme un véhicule à théâtre un
véhicule à music hall un véhicule
affiner ma est absolument pas comme un
appareil de télévision tant et si bien
que les gens sont ravis de voir un
chanteur derrière un micro sur une scène
musicale de voir les acteurs sur une
scène de théâtre de voir des films
bon on murray ou mais une voix rarement
la télévision on peut dire qu'à cannes
au départ il ya une recherche
personnelle pour essayer d'intégrer
un acteur un danseur un chanteur un
écran télévision
les critiques les plus acerbes que je
reçois c'est ça bouge trop effectivement
ça bouge trop et je le veux comme ça
parce que j'estime que la télévision
n'est pas un art de tout repos on doit
pas voir la télévision bien assis dans
son fauteuil il faut protester
remuez se secouer bref à voir en sorte
une des réactions brutales devant son
poste
la télévision est un instrument qui va
vous trouver chez vous il faut donc
qu'il tienne sa réputation il faisant
que secouer les gens chez eux
maintenant on dit également que je sers
mal les chanteurs que je les cache
derrière une mise en scène exubérante
enfin en tant que mc aime bien les
chanteurs au bout d'un quart d'heure
quel qu'il soit totalement tous les
styles il devient extrêmement rares
joueurs si on démontre comme dans les
émissions que vous n'y a absolument
aucune recherche de présentation au bout
d'un quart d'heure
moi j'ai la nausée c'est bien que les
décors et la mise en scène
autrement dit l'intégration télévisées
ou télévisuelle d'un chanteur dans
l'écran 3d est commun ni cuisson c'est
de l'herald isme autrement dit il ya un
symbole l'attend au tour du chanteur fer
forgé par un décor ou formé par une
heure par une suite de montage
autrement dit il essaie de traduire
visuellement ce qui n'est que jamais que
la reproduction d'un disque
autrement dit il savait intégrer le
chanteur dans son décor et faire du
décor l'élément visuel de la chanson le
fonds recommande la forme ça revient à
la surface comme la sacem sociable
l'enterrement de qu'en déduit s'éteint
et une chanson caricaturale des
enterrements la nouvelle orléans
alors donc la chanson du textuellement
nous étions 200 un enterrement de
corning y sort donc 200 figurants ça va
de soi j'aurais évidemment vers les
dessins petits bouts de papier mais je
pensais que c'était drôle de serre une
fête macabre à la fin d'un show qui
prétendait est une distraction
les champs elysées
[Musique]
par contre dans le domaine nous allons
aborder maintenant toutes les fantaisies
sont permises dans le domaine des
variétés et avec une image on peut faire
des milliers d'image on peut décortiquer
une image on peut faire dire aux gens et
aux choses le contraire de ce qu'ils
pensent
ça c'est le domaine des magiciens des
variétés et en tête de tout cela il ya
un garçon temps je n'ai pas besoin de
faire l'éloge est dans le nom viennent
tout de suite à votre pensée c'est jean
christophe averty que nous allons
retrouver maintenant christophe la
télévision française ses débuts quand
nous l'avons connue était très libre
dans le ton et dans l'esprit
puis le ton s'est fait un peu plus grave
et l'esprit s'est fait un peu moins
légers
heureusement vous avez fait votre
apparition en ce moment là vous avez
libéré la télévision de la pire des
oppressions l'oppression de la forme et
l'oppression de l'image et toutes les
voler en éclats les têtes sont parties
d'un côté les jambes sont partis de
l'autre côté et enfin grâce à vous on a
inventé ce mouvement qui déplace les
lignes détesté par le koweit mais très
apprécié par les téléspectateurs
donc je pense que le trucage
électronique qui était une manière de
poétiser de télévision dit trop souvent
et terre à terre et se contente de
filmer ce qu'elle voit je pense que la
télévision et à pully sierre elle
constate que c'était de rater leur
telles personnes sont portées devant
telle et telle caméra et puis c'est tout
et on se contente de peu je pense à la
télévision une des voix impressionnante
et lyon c'est de faire rêver et le rêve
se fait avec des images la vie à sid
morrow monotone et assez sinistre assez
morose alors les images que je fabrique
sont des images jamais vues
du moins par mois je pense qu'on a pas
non plus si bien que je ne comprends pas
les gens qui n'aiment pas mes émissions
il devrait même s'il ne leur plaît pas
être content de votre chose de différent
at on pu voir des assassinats des
histoires de cocu des meurtres
accident un bébé qui passe dans une
moulinette et plus drôle que n'importe
quel président en
get away je suis bien là je m'en suis
bien sorti janadi a sorti je pense que
maintenant pour éviter de plus nous
embarquer dans une série sciences qui
nous amènerait très loin à la porte
je pense qu'il est bon de laisser à max
devrait nation stabilité de m'entraîne
son voile pour vous madame il faut
prendre de vraies si j'ose dire comment
l'en sentir grâce aux trucages qu'ils
expliquent cela nos téléspectateurs le
trucage consiste à faire un montage
analogue à la au montage photographique
en prenant un signal qui va permettre de
découper comme un important pièce le
signal l'image fournie par la caméra et
dans un décor
l'image fournie par la caméra reprend sa
place dans le trou colonna ainsi
constitué et on met autour un décor qui
peut changer
qui peut être bien d'autres images
toutes les images dont nous disposons en
particulier nous pouvons remettre le
haut personnage sur nous mêmes sur
toutes les images que nous fournit le
plateau à ce moment là et en l'intérieur
des personnages on peut aussi
ap la place des personnages mettre ces
images dont nous disposons le trucage
électronique ne consiste pas simplement
à faire que des incrustations le
générateur des faits nous livre un
certain nombre de volets et des
médaillons en particulier ce rectangle
de largeur de hauteur variable et
d'emplacements réglable messieurs
georges de caunes va vous demander dans
quelques instants de jouer avec ce
médaillon mais si ça doit faire une
démonstration c'est une scène classique
un français moyen rentrant chez lui
trouve sa bouteille de vin rouge
ordinaires ne pense pas à mal sans vous
imaginez qu'une caméra télévision suisse
et mouvements serre
se remplit un verre de vin rouge mais il
montre l'étiquette par la même occasion
sans le vouloir il ya cependant toujours
parmi les téléspectateurs quelques
personnages un peu pointilleux
quelquefois un sénateur homme charmant
par nature mais toujours un peu diligent
et qui aurait tendance à voir des
arrière pensées oui il y en a pas qui se
dit tiens monsieur macha montre la
marque de talent va qui nous vient d'une
série redevance de france où le vin
comment ce n'est pas frelaté donc pas
d'arrière pensée pour qu'il n'y ait pas
de souci quelconque monsieur vous avez
vous servir et nous à la régie de
l'enfer en sorte que personne ne puisse
dire quoi que ce soit sur le geste banal
que vous accomplissez servez-vous de vin
rouge et buvait tranquillement
[Musique]
voilà resservez vous vous en prie
monsieur le sens caché des tic est niée
par an le cas syrien nous ferons le
nécessaire
ils nous montreront ainsi qu'en france
ni le vent ni nos émissions
ils sont coupés de lamentations voilà il
s'agit de faire à 7 boutons par deux
c'est un bouton en dessin alors je vais
cadres et ne font des corps sur une
caméra c'est la 4 qu'il n'est pas
toujours pas branché mais qui ne
laissera bientôt cameramen villa cavrois
ça et le cube fera la place du mouton
ce cube bleu dans l'espace vous aurez
donc à sauter par dessus ce cube et vous
sauterez par la même occasion part de
ses boutons sont des saints dans ce lieu
oui vous par exemple à ab toute la ville
a sauté et tout le monde a sauté
une partie de ce bouton voix le dessin
est cadré 6e tu vois bien un accès
complet à la une près de lacolle voilà
c'est très bien ça va ça va vigeant
laura davies ensemble non de trop voilà
les deux mots l'image max de la cadre
structure centre le mouton faisant la
nique aux ânes du match 20 cadres encore
voilà très bien
enfin bouger là de maintenant la deux
c'était cadré regarde-moi à deux motards
[Musique]
mademoiselle très gentil des serviettes
pour rendre le passage des faire le
mouton tu donnes la surimpression match
[Musique]
bien vous vous les enlevez cette
construction
allez-y sauter par dessus
allez hop bon passer de compter comme ça
plusieurs fois
oui c'était aujourd'hui un bouton comme
ceux d'un escalier voilà voilà à la
continuer hop bien alors tout à
s'habiller en place allons-y frêle
chanter le mouton ou ai-je fait ici de
faire une chose comme ça c'est possible
pas du tout impossible sur sa tombe et
non à lisbonne
procédons d'image au une fois allons-y
lundi
et bien dit sois bon souvenir aux
boutons à moi je voudrais bien je crois
que nous devons transmettre aux morts
[Musique]
voilà alors je vais sur situé devant
nous allons c'est avec de braine et tous
les techniciens qui sont ici la tête de
ce monsieur on va la mettre le corps de
la petite fille alors c'est très simple
on couvre le corps de ce monsieur avec
une un voile bleu de manière à incruster
son corps dans le fond du décor voilà
vous ne bougez plus vous avez bien cette
caméra et quand la petite fille
on va lui mettre la cagoule sur la tête
attention hein ça c'est pas mal mais
c'est voilà voilà
alors de brel à toi élargi la petite
élargie de petite fille ou
réciproquement
on dégage cette attention attendez tout
fille de monsieur up attention hop voilà
fraîchement couvriront se retire georges
oui tous les deux de manière à ce que
l'on puisse faire le trucage tranquille
ferait grossir un peu la tête de la
petite fille là encore encore encore et
à remonter et george est un peu voilà
revenu et des bravo monsieur
et voilà mon cher jean christophe
l'heure de la confusion c'est d'abord il
faut que je me suis bien où je suis
dedans oui à ce niveau je vous dis c'est
très con les libéraux déçus parce qu'on
l'attendait il ya le temps
guillaume gillet communal qui reste est
soit deux heures puis c'est très commode
quand on change de directeur chez ia que
furent la honte je m'en servais de la
toile non non je n'insiste pas alors
j'aimerais que j'abrège nos commentaires
merci jacques astor et toujours je vous
remercie d'être venus je reviens sur
agnès elle arrive je remercie tous les
professionnels de la télévision et je
remercie ceux sans qui le veulent de
télévision n'aurais pas de raison
d'exister
le touch / public les téléspectateurs
[Musique]
jean christophe averty eu les api est la
principale cause de destruction de la
culture télévisuelle
car ce pistolet qui sut qui servent
d'abord et la liberté non le service
manque total un enfermement vivement
total le rappeur est un pistolet qu'on a
mis dans la main un spectateur pour
tirer sur l'écran qui lui tire également
des idioties sol
c'était un instrument défense mais en
mitraillant et en brisant le spectacle
continue il ne peut plus avoir à la fin
d'une soirée que des fragments
d'ignorance et l'empreinte connaissance
un spectacle se jugent complètement je
regarde très peu la télévision comme si
quand je n'ai pas d'ambition qui passe
je vous dis franchement elle n'intéresse
guère radio vous l'avez pas y avait plus
longtemps mais quand j'ai choisi un
programme lorsqu'il est bon ou mauvais
je le regarde jusqu'au bout ça c'est le
théâtre nom de taille et lorsque je veux
me puisse faire un jugement complet sur
ce programme mais chip que cela et je
passe à faire des petites piques comme
un petit pantin devant un écran qui me
dit fut saisie de ces inepties
je n'ai rien dans la tête qu'un miroir
brisé donc le zappeur et d'une chose
effroyable maintenant la multiplicité
des chaînes que vous dit mme bernard
être un choix possible
c'est un non choix futurs car plus il ya
deux chaînes muayad yeux pour regarder
chaque chaîne
les gens ne regardent plus rien et je
suis content certains soirs quand je
rentre tard vers disons quand j'entre
tour pardonnez moi alors du print yb
entre 20h et 20h30 paris et plein de
bagnols il ya plein de gens dans les
rues qui circulent il ne regarde en rien
à la télé
ils sont heureux parce qu'ils montrent
maintenant une fois express ont pu
rentrer chez eux pour savoir le prime
time est un devoir sacré si l'on est
français sur les greens de stoneham et
120 oeuvres une culture générale
on arrive chez soi à 10 heures et à ce
moment là on commence à regarder quelque
chose qui vous apprend quelques jours
alors de prison cultivés dans des oeufs
alors vous êtes contre l'access prime
time
oui c'est tout lier ces mots dérisoire
dérivé de l'anglais tous et marketing
tous ces politiques tous ces noms ans
ning tout ce jargon structuraliste ou
non mais je savais pas qu'on pouvait
penser galles savait pas partout de
culture générale aujourd'hui la petite
boîte noire
les parts de marché mais tout ce fourbi
arabe finale c'est du bavardage digne
d'ailleurs en voit les conséquences
maintenant aujourd'hui